before we go a Colorado educator who
began his career as a custodian is back
in school this week this time as the
principal Michael Atkins started his
first semester as principal of Denver's
Stedman elementary school already very
familiar with the school system for more
than three decades in fact Atkins has
been a student than a gender than a
teacher but as a young student he did
not see a future in education after
experiencing racial discrimination in
the classroom that all changed when he
realized he could inspire students to
celebrate each other's differences make
sure you write your own story and if
someone has something to do with your
story let them edit it right do not let
them create it
I like that let them edit it do not let
them create an action says he takes
pride in every job he's had and says
each one has helped him achieve the
success he has today that's a great
achievement congratulations Michael
Atkins but imagine what that means to
him though yes there who started there
as a custodian climbed to every step
climbed every single step and now he's
in the head chair but I won't forget
that no one else can write your story
you're the one that has to create it
great advice we won't forget that